대화를 하다 보면
아, 이제 무슨 얘기를 해야 하지?
대화 주제가 떨어져서
어색해지는 순간이 있습니다
이번 3분 레벨업에서는
7. 대화가 끊기지 않는
66가지 포인트를 바탕으로
어색한 상대와는 친해지고
이미 친한 상대와는
더욱더 긴밀한 사이가 될 수 있는
대화 주제 무한 생성법
두 가지를 알려드릴게요
1. 평소 습관 말하기
혜정씨도 와인 마시는 취미가 있는지 몰랐네요
네, 저는 소주나 다른 술들보다는
와인이 가장 잘 맞더라고요
만약 대화 주제가 와인으로 잡혔다면
와인은 입안이 뻑뻑할 정도로
탄인감이 짱짱한 게 좋더라고요
와인 자체만으로도
충분히 즐거운 대화를 나눌 수 있습니다
하지만 아직 어색한 사이에선
역시 근본은 까베르네 소비뇽이죠
까쇼가 은근히 배녀감도 좋잖아
아, 네, 그건 그렇죠
계속 그 주제에 관해서만 얘기하면
대화는 그리 오래가지 못합니다
그뿐만 아니라
은근 알맹이 없는 느낌마저 드는데요
왜냐하면 아직 덜 친한 사이에서 대화는
상대와 내가 서로 평소에 어떤 사람인지를
파악해가는 과정이거든요
그렇기 때문에
저는 매번 새로운 와인을 마셔보는 편이에요
실패하더라도 다양하게 많은 걸 경험하면 좋잖아요
제가 원래도 호기심이 좀 많은 편이라서요
자신의 평소 성격을 보여줄 수 있는
어떤 습관을 말하거나
혜정씨는 와인 드실 때 주로 새로운 와인을 고르시는 편인가요?
아니면 평소에 즐겨 마시는 와인 위주로 선택하는 편인가요?
상대방이 자신의 평소 성격을 말할 수 있도록 질문을 하면
저는 살짝 늘 마시던 것들만 마시는 편이에요
다른 와인들도 마셔보고 싶긴 한데
괜히 실패할까 봐
결국 익숙한 것들만 찾게 되더라고요
원래 제가 평소에도 겁이 좀 많은 편이라서요
단순히 관심사가 비슷한 사람을 넘어서
그래도 다음엔 왕대씨랑 새로운 와인도 한번 도전해봐야겠어요
아니 저는 겁이 많아서 새로운 걸 시도해보고 싶어도 못하는데
왕대씨는 그러지 않는 것 같아서요
전보다 서로에 관해서 더 많이 알게 되고
한층 가까워진 기분을 느낄 수 있죠
디캔팅 하시죠
네?
늘 마시던 와인도 얼마든지 새롭게 태어날 수 있어요
누가 만지느냐에 따라서
칠해산 와인이군요
저런 높이에서 디캔팅을
덩치를 말칸 태버리다
두 번째
매너있게 무례한 질문하기
대화를 하다 보면
이런 것까지 물어봐도 될까?
깊어가지고
자체 검열을
타고납니다
그런데 만약
자체 검열을 하지 않고
그냥 냅다다 물어본다면
소개팅 약에서 웨이트한테 소개팅 상대 뺏긴 사람은 여밖에 없을 듯?
아 징심대 웃겨
야니 진짜로 내가 그렇게 매력이 없나?
응 잘 알고 있네
나 지금 진짜 장난칠기 비난이거든?
엥? 장난 안 쳤는데?
야니 왜 그래?
왜?
내게 어떤 포인트에서 그렇게 매력이 없는 건데?
아무랄까
여능 일당 다 괜찮야
괜찮은데
근데 눈치 묘륵이 남자로서의 매력이 없단 말이지
그냥 얘 곁에 사람이 여유도 없고?
아 불행
학매 뒤로 형적인 매력이 없어?
형적인 매력?
야 정도면 괜찮을 텐데
글쎄 아닐걸?
아 진짜 괴이 없네
근데 희진아 너는 지금까지 몇 명이랑 해봤냐?
뭐라고?
군인께 몇 명이랑 실...
아무리 친해도
이렇게 궁금한 거 다 물어보면
그냥 싹 무례한 인간이 되는 겁니다
근데 또 그거 아시나요?
상대가
선뜻 대답하기 힘든 주제로
대화를 나누는 것만큼
더욱 긴밀한 사이가 되는 방법도
없다는 사실을요
그렇기 때문에 상대에게
무언가 무례한 질문을 하고 싶을 때는
아 구해
근데 희진아
야 묘야냐면 위롭해도 됐겨?
우선 1차로
오 하나만 물어봐도 될까?
라며 운을 띄웁니다
응 뭔데?
여기야 지금까지 몇 명이랑 했는지
위롭해도 돼?
그런 다음
뭐뭐를 물어봐도 될까?
라고
무례할 수도 있는
그 질문을 해도 되는지
상대에게 먼저
의사를 물어봅니다
그러면 상대방 입장에서도
야니니는
그런 게 도대체 왜 궁금한데?
직방으로
무례한 질문을 받을 때보다는
훨씬
덜 무례하게 느껴집니다
아 물론
무례한 건 맞지만요
그니가 그게 왜 궁금해냐면
그냥 궁금해져?
와 그거 참
증멸되지 않은 이유다
그치?
대답하기 싫으면 그냥 여명이야
3분 안에 레벨업
비치키를 구독하시고
실전 자기개발 버프를
받아가세요